80 % des pères québécois s'absentent du
travail après la naissance d'un enfant
on dit que le régime de congé parental
au québec est un modèle mais qu'en est
il ailleurs
saviez-vous qu avant d'entrer en vigueur
du régime québécois à peine 25% des
parts prenait un congé après la
naissance d'un enfant comme on disait
depuis l'instauration ce régime c'est
maintenant 80 % des sommes qui vont
prendre un congé de paternité dans le
reste du pays c'est à peine 13% des
hommes qui optent pour un congé parental
et c'est ça que le gouvernement fédéral
soit améliorée car des études de l' ocde
le démontre plus les pères s'impliquent
moins il ya de discrimination à l'égard
des femmes dans le milieu de travail
il ya des pays qui offrent des congés de
paternité beaucoup plus long la corée du
sud par exemple offrent aux pères 53
semaines la france 28 semaines mais
encore et comme en france à peine 4 %
des pères utilisent ce genre de congé
pourquoi en raison des risques
financiers
les prestations sont pas assez généreuse
et les hommes préfèrent rester sur le
marché du travail
d'autres pays comme la norvège ont une
approche plus flexible les prestations
sont plus généreuses et les semaines de
congés même si elles sont moins
nombreuses peuvent se prendre sur une
période de trois ans ce qui permet au
parent de s'occuper des enfants de
continuer à travailler à temps partiel
résultats 95% des norvégiens prennent du
temps à la maison pour s'occuper de leur
bébé
[Musique]